the team brief sports and community  awards are back we're transforming  Dornish leisure center into a glitzy  glamorous and professional venue so we  can almost double the numbers of those  attending you can now nominate a person  team school business charity or group in  a range of categories and a shortlisted  their achievements will be celebrated at  the final on the 1st of May nominations  are easy to do just click on the link  below to get started this is your chance  to surprise someone and give them the  recognition they deserve it's fantastic  to see all the nominees and their  families at the final on the night as  they're recognized for their dedication  and achievement towards making the  district of team bridge such an  extraordinary place to live